[Music]
from sweet children's movies to Wild
action spectacles animated movies come
in all shapes colors and sizes in the
coming months we can also look forward
to a wide range of animated movies this
video introduces you to the upcoming
Cinema highlights
most of you have heard of them Paw
Patrol the helpers on Four Paws the
series has become an indispensable part
of any children's room and PAW Patrol
the movie was also a huge success in
2021 it's only natural that Paramount
has given the go-ahead for a sequel
about Chase and his friends at the end
of September it's time for Paw Patrol
the mighty movie in it a mysterious
meteorite strikes turning The Lovable
four-legged friends of Adventure City
into mighty superheroes but with great
power comes great responsibility mayor
Humdinger the PAW Patrol's ruthless
Nemesis breaks out of prison and forms a
dangerous alliance with mad scientist
Victoria Vance their goal steal the
pup's superpowers to turn themselves
into Super Villains it is now up to the
mighty Paws of the super dogs to prevent
Adventure City from imminent disaster
and to put the villains in their place
the new adventure of the four-legged
friends will premiere on September 29th
the creators of films such as Encanto
and Beauty and the Beast have the next
animated Adventure coming up we're
talking about Disney's wish the story
revolves around 17 year old Asha who
lives in a world where dreams come true
when she sends a desperate wish into the
sky one day she is surprised by a cosmic
force a bubbly sphere of energy called
star together with the goat Valentino
Asha embarks on a breathtaking journey
to save her dear home wish brings back
the symbol of the Wishing Star that we
already know from classics like
Pinocchio Peter Pan and the Princess and
the Frog the film was directed by Disney
Legend Chris Buck famous for Frozen and
Pocahontas for example the film style is
remarkable is a mixture of traditional
hand-drawn animation and CGI the film
can be watched in cinemas from November
22nd
when Universal Pictures and the creators
and the minions get together a lot of
fun is bound to happen after the Super
Mario Brothers movie the next project is
just around the corner migration in this
heartwarming animation comedy we joined
Mac Mallard an ordinary duck father who
lives with his family in an idyllic Pond
however the peaceful Life Changes
suddenly when mother Pam feels the urge
to explore the world beyond the pond
Wanderlust finally takes over when a
group of migratory Ducks stop at the
pond and Pam teen Sun Dax and duckling
daughter Gwen share exciting stories
about the wide world they convinced duck
dad Mac to go on an adventure-filled
family trip to Tropical Jamaica
accompanied by Uncle Dan however the
inexperienced vacationers are confronted
with unforeseen challenges when they
don't end up in Jamaica as planned but
in a big city the new comedy will be
released in cinemas just in time for
Christmas on December 22nd
Pixar fans can look forward to March
because that's when the new film Elio
will be released in it the boy bearing
the same name has to protect the Earth
though not at home but in the depths of
outer space his mother Olga is the head
of a top secret military project this
leads to the first encounter with aliens
in the adventure that follows he must
not only prove to the aliens but above
all to himself that the true beauty of
Being Human lies in being oneself the
movie by the makers of Coco will hit
theaters on March 1st 2024
foreign
hardly anyone was expecting it but eight
years after the third part of the Kung
Fu Panda series the franchise is getting
a fourth movie in 2024. Poe will once
again assume his responsibility as the
Dragon Warrior according to initial
reports he will leave the familiar
Valley Of Peace and enter a vibrant
Metropolis that is haunted by a menacing
Darkness our hero faces a new and
dangerous foe the chameleon a ruthless
villain with a frightening ability to
summon enemies from Poe's past among
them are former students of Master Shifu
and a dark crane who wants to eliminate
the pandas once and for all but that's
not everything not only does Poe bear
the burden of having to face his most
formidable enemy but he also has to look
for a worthy successor whether the
fourth part will be the end of Poe is
something that we don't know at this
point but either way Kung Fu Panda 4
will certainly be another movie suitable
for the whole family the new adventure
can be enjoyed from March 8 2024.
The Adventures of Miles Morales in the
spider-verse movies are among the best
animated superhero stories ever the
first part even won an Oscar for good
reason Spider-Man across the
spider-verse was likewise a great
success so we are all the more pleased
about the upcoming third part Spider-Man
beyond the spider verse the new
adventure takes us to a gloomy reality
known as Earth 42 where Spider-Man is
only a legend instead his dark
doppelganger miles G Morales roams about
as the villain Prowler miles is trapped
in this Bleak World while his father
must confront the dangerous spot and
faces death can Gwen and the spider gang
find miles in time and prevent the
impending doom the movie was actually
supposed to be released on March 29 2024
however many insiders have long been
aware that this date would be impossible
to keep as part 2 already struggled to
make it on time then on top of that Kim
the writers an actor strike and the
project was postponed altogether for an
indefinite period of time we are eagerly
awaiting the next news and we'll let you
know as soon as there are any updates on
the theatrical release of Spider-Man and
Beyond the spiderverse
inside out from 2015 is still considered
one of the most successful Pixar films
of all time absolutely deserved and of
course it also won the Academy Award for
best animated feature it was all the
more astonishing that nothing was ever
mentioned about a possible sequel for
years but at Disney's d23 Expo last year
the time finally came and Inside Out 2
was officially announced as we already
know the new film makes a decent time
Jump namely into the adolescence of main
character Riley needless to say the
emotions Joy sadness fear anger and
disgust are back but it's entirely
possible that other emotions will be
added during this exciting phase of Life
at the d23 Expo Pixar CEO Pete doctor
revealed that there may be as many as 27
emotions in the upcoming sequel the
planned theatrical release date is June
14th 2024. it is without a doubt one of
the big animation highlights of the year
Despicable Me is a modern classic but
it's been six years since the third
installment hit theaters since then
there have been at least the minion
spin-off movies to keep us laughing now
as announced by Universal Pictures and
illumination together the fourth part of
the main movie series will finally hit
theaters next year unfortunately we
still don't know anything about the plot
but Chris Renaud will be the director
again he already directed the first two
movies the movie is expected to open in
theaters on July 3rd 2024 as soon as
there's more news about the plot we will
of course let you know straight away
The Lion King fans were Overjoyed when
Disney announced that Mufasa The Lion
King would be a new animated movie based
around the franchise the prequel will
reveal the origins of the iconic story
showing us the world of young Mufasa
before he became the mighty king in the
process we should learn more about the
bond between Mufasa and his brother Scar
and about their break that would change
the fate of the Savannah forever in the
new film we are supposed to get to know
both sides of Scar the sweet and lovable
one as well as the extremely cunning one
that teaches us to fear Him the plot of
Mufasa The Lion King will be inspired
closely by the book A Tale of Two
Brothers which was published back in
1994 and takes us further into the story
of Mufasa and Scar there for example we
learn how the Young Prince taka became
Scar and got his nickname the expected
release date is July 5th 2024 certainly
a musty occasion for all The Lion King
fans
those were some of the animated movies
we are most excited about which movie
are you looking forward to the most and
did we miss any promising ones perhaps
let us know in the comments
[Music]
foreign